[Music]
today we have around
80 people in moscow who if they want to
can be vaccinated tomorrow
and fly back on sunday we expect now
every week the same quantity
so long as the vaccines in germany are
scarce
i have no fears because it's a
recommended vaccination from the who
it has a good international reputation
so from that
i have no concerns
[Music]
i wanted to receive the vaccine myself
quicker than we would get it in germany
as a 19 year old i would receive it far
too late
and my father is an at risk patient and
i'm doing it for him
actually because i want to protect my
family and i don't want to bring
the virus home i would probably get my
turn at the end of the year
and i don't want to wait that long i had
other options such as serbia
israel iraq and the united states but
all fell away for various reasons
so this was the best offer
you